mr. speaker the Prime Minister
mr. mr. speaker mr. speaker I know that
the thoughts of the whole house will be
with all those caught up in the horrific
incident in Strasbourg last night and we
stand ready to give whatever support the
French authorities may need mr. speaker
today I will have meetings possibly many
meetings with ministerial colleagues and
others just a normal day in the office
then Prime Minister I would also want to
share the condolences for the tragic
events in the beautiful city of
Strasbourg last year the Prime Minister
told us that there wasn't going to be a
general election and then there was this
week she told us she wasn't going to
pull the meaningful vote and then she
did can I ask her now if she's going to
rule out having a general election and a
people's vote yes can I can I say to the
Honourable lady first of all that I
think that a general election at this
point in time would not be in the
national interest
[Applause]
and secondly and secondly as she will
have heard me say before in this house I
think we should respect the result of
the referendum that took place in 2016
Nigel Mills given what we could call
uncertainty about the future of the
withdrawal agreements could the permits
to give people some certainty that's EU
Nationals in the UK that whatever
happens to that deal they will be
allowed to stay on roughly the same
terms as are in that draft agreement
wonderful friend raises an important
point because I know that EU nationals
living here in the United Kingdom will
be concerned about what might happen in
the circumstances if a deal is not
agreed we've been very clear as a
government obviously they withdraw an
agreement that we've agreed does respect
the rights and protect and guarantee the
rights of EU citizens living here but in
the unlikely event of no deal I've been
clear that this government will still
protect EU citizens rights and we would
wish that we wish to know would wish to
know that actually other EU governments
would respect the rights of UK citizens
thank you mr. speaker Thank You mr.
speaker I'm sure the whole house will
join me in joining us joining the prime
minister in condemning the shootings in
Strasbourg and extending our sympathy to
the families of those that have been
killed or injured there mr. speaker I'm
delighted to see the Prime Minister back
in a place after a little journeys
having told the media this morning
having told the media this morning that
she's made progress can she now update
the house on what changes she has
secured to her deal I did travel to
Europe yesterday and meet a number of
Heads of Government of the Commission
european union council that's precisely
because I had listened to concerns that
were raised in this house and have taken
those concerns to Europe and no one is
in any dome one that I met yesterday is
in any doubt about the strength of
concern there is in this house on this
issue of the duration of the backstop
but I'm interested that the right
honourable gentleman wants to know what
Probus we have made because actually the
right honourable gentleman couldn't care
less what I bring back from Brussels
he's been clear he's being clear
whatever comes back from Brussels he's
going to vote against it because all he
wants to do is to create chaos in our
economy
[Applause]
damage damage division division in our
society and damage to Corbin Jeremy
Corbyn it's very clear mr. speaker
nothing has changed if she needed
if she needed any clarification mr.
speaker if she needed any clarification
about the temporary nature of the
backstop she need have gone to Europe
she could have just asked her Attorney
General who said it indoors indefinitely
as the Prime Minister may recall when
she left when she left on her journey we
were about to start day four of a
five-day debate on the deal since the
Prime Minister has not achieved any
changes either to withdrawal agreement
or the future partnership can she now
confirm that we will have the concluding
days of debates and votes within the
next seven days before the house rises
for the Christmas recess gentlemen I had
discussions with a number of people
yesterday and I have made some progress
but there is but of course there is an
EU council meeting there are further
discussions to be held he asks about the
meaningful vote the meaningful vote has
been deferred and the date of that vote
will be announced in the normal way the
business motion will be agreed and
discussed in the usual way
where who says when all i'll tell
members on the other side when we've had
a meaningful vote we had it in the
referendum on 2000
and if he wants a meaningful date I'll
give him one 29th of March 2019 when we
leave the European Union
namiko be totally and absolutely
unacceptable
this house this house agreed a program
motion this house agreed the five days
of debate this house agreed when the
vote was going to take place the
government tried to unilaterally pull
that and deny this house denied this
house the chance of a vote on this
crucial matter the Prime Minister and
the government have already been found
to be in contempt of Parliament
her behavior today is just contemptuous
of this Parliament
mr. speaker the Prime Minister's
appalling behavior needs to be held to
account by this house as indeed the
people of this country are more and more
concerned about the ongoing chaos at the
centre of her government when she made
her Lancaster High Court order order
calm on both sides of the house the
quest order the questions will be heard
however long it takes and so will the
answers don't try to shout down all you
do is wear out your voices and you won't
succeed amen end of subject
Jeremy Corbyn mr. speaker when the Prime
Minister made her Lancaster House speech
she set out her negotiating objectives
and they're worth looking at and quoting
the first objective is crucial will
provide certainty wherever we can does
the current situation look or feel like
certainty can the Prime Minister mark
her own home work on this matter
and indeed we have at every stage at
every stage the right honourable
gentleman said we wouldn't get agreement
in December we did he said we wouldn't
get the implementation period in March
we did he said we wouldn't get a
withdrawal agreement under political
declaration and we and we did concerns
concerns have been raised concerns have
been raised about the backstop and as I
said we continue those discussions and
no one yesterday was left in any doubt
about the strength of feeling in this
house but of course we all know what the
right on will gentleman's answer to the
backstop is ignore the referendum and
stay in the European Union
if there's an agreement why won't the
Prime Minister put that agreement to a
vote of this house the Federation of
small businesses says that planning
ahead is put impossible many many other
people around this country find planning
ahead impossible because all they see is
chaos at the heart of government and an
inability to plan anything for the
future
yesterday the cross party Select
Committee including conservative MPs for
the committee for departing exiting the
European Union unanimously found the
Prime Minister's deal and I quote fails
to offer sufficient clarity or certainty
about the future will the Prime Minister
give the country at least some certainty
and categorically rule out the option of
No Deal the way to ensure there is no no
deal is to agree a deal that's the way
[Applause]
the right honourable gentleman the right
honorable gentleman talks about the
impact on businesses I'll turn in what
will have an impact on businesses and
down this country what we learned just a
few days ago that the Shadow Chancellor
wants to change the law order the prime
minister's reply must be heard and it
will be the prime minister businesses
will be affected by the fact that the
Shadow Chancellor wants to change the
law so the trade unions in this country
can go on strike in solidarity with any
strike anywhere in the world that's not
that may be solidarity with trade unions
it's not solidarity with small
businesses and it's not solidarity with
the ordinary working people who would
pay the price of labor
speaker my question was would the Prime
Minister rule out No Deal
she has failed to do that can I tell the
Prime Minister this sorry saga is
frustrating for businesses for workers
and many actually behind her as well
many they were trying to work
constructively to find a solution
yesterday yesterday her former brexit
Minister said a new customs union with
the EU could be the basis for a
parliamentary consensus when is she
going to start listening to people that
want actually to find a constructive
solution to this rather than denying
Parliament the right to debate it and
vote on her deal well we all know one
group of people that don't want to find
a constructive solution is the Labour
Party
and that's what we see on the other side
that's what we see on the other side of
the chamber no plan no clue no brexit
[Applause]
speaker
mr. speaker the time for dis ring and
delay is over the Prime Minister the
Prime Minister has negotiated her deal
she's right honourable gentlemen will be
heard Jeremy Corbyn mr. speaker the time
for dis ring and delay by this
government is over
the Prime Minister has negotiated her
deal she's told us it's the best and
only deal available there could be no
more excuses
no more running away put it before
Parliament and let's have the vote
whatever happens with her conservative
leadership vote today it is utterly
irrelevant to the lives of people across
our country it does nothing to solve the
government's inability to get a deal
that works for the whole country
she's already been found to be in
contempt of Parliament will she now put
this deal before Parliament and halts
this escalating crisis which is so
damaging to the lives of so many people
in this country we all know from the
multiplicity of changes in plan we've
seen from the Labour Party there's one
thing we can be sure about but whatever
you turn comes next in Labour's policy
he'll send out
but Ord I said a moment ago the leader
of the opposition must be heard and
belatedly he was and the Prime Minister
will be heard the Prime Minister
whatever change in neighbor policy we'll
see he sent out his henchmen to reveal
it all to the world the inconstant
Gardner
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I say to the right honourable gentleman
when I say to the right honourable
gentleman I think it's time somebody
will explain it to the leader of the
Opposition little bit later
[Applause]
can I say to the ride on wall jack
[Applause]
when I say to the right honourable
gentleman that he should be honest with
people he should be honest with people
about his position he couldn't care less
about brexit what he wants to do is
bring down the government create
uncertainty so division and crash our
economy
the biggest threat the biggest threat to
people and to this country isn't leaving
the EU it's a Corbin government
[Applause]
Paul master turn
Thank You mr. speaker a few weeks ago
Ben McKenzie from millstone of people at
East with high school took his own life
having been the victim of cruel online
threats and bullying on social media and
his mobile phone he was just 13 years
old nearly 10,000 pounds has been raised
in his memory for a beautiful inside and
out of Scottish charity that supports
the families of victims of child
suicides they can the Prime Minister set
out what this government is going to do
to tackle cyberbullying not just to
support an empire of victims but to
deter and prevent children who may be
engaging in these acts not realizing the
consequences they can have because no
family should be in during a Christmas
without their child due to suicide can I
say to my honourable friend he has
raised an extremely serious issue and
I'm sure the thoughts of the whole house
and the condolences of the whole house
we've hit Ben his family at this
terrible time and this terrible tragedy
that has occurred and as I say he's
raised an incredibly serious issue
because this question of cyberbullying
is one that we do need to address in
both ways as he says both working with
the Internet companies in relation to
what is put out on their their platforms
with working with schools to help people
to you know to recognize this material
and to deal with it but also to support
those children who could as my humble
friend says be the victims and who might
be all those children who might be
carrying out these attacks and what our
consultation showed last year on
Internet safety was that despite a range
of voluntary initiatives and good work
by a range of charities and I commend
the work of the Scottish charity
beautiful inside and out and the amount
of money that's been raised this does
remain a serious issue for millions and
people millions of people I know the
Scottish government has been addressing
this with their respect for all approach
we are looking working funded the UK
safer internet center that's providing
guidance for schools but this is an
issue we should all take very seriously
in the government will continue to work
on this
Thank You mr. speaker can I associate
myself with the remarks of the prime
minister on cyber building and indeed on
the terrible tragedy
yesterday in Strasbourg Mr Speaker we
were promised strong and stable we were
promised to vote on the brexit deal but
this Prime Minister can't even do her
own job because of the Tory Civil War
this government mr. speaker is an
embarrassment christmas is just two
weeks away will the Prime Minister bring
forward to Munich for both on the brakes
that deal
next week discussions that we're having
with European leaders and others and
those discussions will continue I think
what matters what matters is that they
are in no doubt about the strength of
feeling about this issue on the duration
of the backstop in this house they are
in no doubt about the strength of
feeling this house that that should be
addressed in a way that has legal force
and that is what we are discussing and
continuing to negotiate with the
European Union as I said earlier the
data factor the date of the deferred
vote on this the date of the the debate
on this will be announced in due course
in the normal way the in Blackford mr.
speaker there is contempt just of
Parliament Parliament voted for a
meaningful walk we should be having the
fort and it should be happening
next week this government is a farce the
Tory Party is in chaos that Prime
Minister is a disgrace for their actions
the reality is that people across
Scotland in the UK are seeing this today
Prime Minister take responsibility do
the right thing resign
[Music]
[Applause]
yes say to the right honourable
gentleman he claims that he makes the
remarks who does about the deference of
the deferring the vote but of course it
is precisely because I have listened and
colleagues in government have listened
to the views of people across this house
that we are pursuing this issue further
with the European Union that is being
respectful of the views that have been
raised in this house mazi thank you up
and down the country have put their
future plans on hold waiting for us here
in Parliament to agree our future
trading relationship with our biggest
and closest movement does the Prime
Minister agree that their interests and
those of their workers and their
suppliers and the country as a whole are
best served by concluding the agreement
with the remaining 27 and on this side
supporting her in the both decision
[Applause]
I think by saying for my friend for his
comments and and agree with him
particularly that we need to ensure that
we do not increase uncertainty and
create more uncertainty and we the
public voted to leave the EU they want
us to secure a deal that delivers on
that result and we shouldn't risk hand
in control of the backseat negotiations
to opposition MPs in Parliament because
that would mean risking delaying brexit
or even stopping brexit none of that
would be in the national interest so I
think we need to get on and deliver a
good brexit for the country
when I stood for election I vowed not to
vote for any brexit deal that was not in
the best interests of Lewisham West and
Paige by pulling at the brexit vote the
Prime Minister must now concede that her
deal is doomed the house and her own
party appear to have no confidence in
her but will she have confidence in the
people and give them a say with a
people's vote
the Honourable lady we have deferred the
vote on the agreement and on the issue
that she raised about putting the vote
back to the people can I say to her as I
have said are they said to the first
questioner the Honourable member from
Bristol and have said in many occasions
in this house this house put its faith
in the votes of the people of this
country when we gave them the referendum
decided to give them the referendum in
2016
people voted to leave the European Union
it is now our duty to deliver on that
[Music]
mr. speaker this house is a duty to make
sure that the next generation live
better lives tomorrow than we live today
so how does my right honourable friend
respond to the Royal College of
Obstetricians and Gynaecologists audit
that found that three quarters of the
hundreds of babies who died or suffered
brain damage each year could be saved by
better care and what steps is the
government taking to ensure that every
expectant mother and unborn baby
receives appropriate monetary raising
what I know is a very important issue
and one that is close to the hearts I
know of many members of this house and
every death or injury of a child is a
tragedy and we have a commitment to
having rates of stillbirth neonatal
deaths and brain injuries after birth by
2025 and that's supported by system-wide
action under our national maternity
safety strategy were increasing
midwifery training places by 25 percent
for investing millions of pounds and
training for staff and in new safety
equipment to ensure that the NHS can
provide world-class care for mothers and
babies but we recognize that this is
something that we need to ensure that we
continue to do all we can and I can give
my honourable friend the reassurance we
will do
Matthew Bennett Kirk Thank You mr.
speaker
as she reflects on her Premiership can I
ask the prime minister which of the
following misjudgment she most regrets
laying down red lines before the brig's
it talks had even begun wasting precious
negotiating time on a general election
or consistently failing to face down the
hardliners on her own benches
and reach out to forge a consensus in
this house and the country I'll tell the
Honorable gentleman the judgment that
was right one it was to accept the vote
of the people in the referendum to
deliver on the vote of the people in the
referendum and deliver a good brexit for
the future of this country
Dameon more bone of my Southport
constituency the Chancellor announcing
the budgeting revitalization from for
our high streets can ask my right
honorable friend when that will be made
available as it will prove a vital
lifeline to my constituency because of
the anti-business policies of labor
control Sefton council when I say to my
honourable friend can I thank you for
highlighting the help that we've
announced to for the high street and
he's absolutely right the leader of the
Opposition may stand up and claim to be
interested in businesses and small
businesses but so often we see the
action of labour councils up and down
the country actually doing exactly the
opposite that's what we have provided
675 million pounds in the future high
streets fund and - so the plans can be
made to help to make high streets and
town centres fit for the future and
we'll be publishing a prospectus for the
fund shortly Katherine West Thank You
mr. speaker can the Prime Minister
confirm which is worse
No Deal or no brexit
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I say can I say to my honourable friend
I think it is important that we do
deliver on brexit for the people of this
both people of this country I believe
that we should do that with a good deal
with the European Union I believe that
is what we've negotiated and I do
believe as my honourable friend from the
central said from the seminary position
but actually the worst thing for this
country would be a Labour government
mr. Kenneth Clark miss finger at a time
of grave national crisis saw the issue
which we all agree was huge importance
to future generations can I write on a
friend think of anything more unhelpful
irrelevant and irresponsible number the
Conservative Party to embark on weeks of
a conservative leadership
can I say
my my right honorable my right honorable
learn unlearn it friend has raised me
important issue and I think it is it is
the impact that those weeks of that
campaign would have on the decision that
the house has to take and the decision
that we have to save the country in
relation to leaving the European Union
because there is no doubt that would go
belong beyond the legislative days of
the 21st of January and it would mean
that the new leader cut were a new
leaders come in that the one the first
things they would have to do would be to
either extend article 50 or rescind
article 50 and that would mean either
delaying or stopping brexit Sean
McDonough away from the madness of her
own MPs can I welcome the prime minister
back to the real world
last week Marian was forced to queue
outside st. George's Hospital Tooting
with a badly infected left leg because
the A&E was full knowing my constituents
can the prime minister tell me how long
will that PQ be should the local NHS get
its way and move the A&E at Centennial
hospital to leafy wealthy Belmont the
honor ladies I'm very concerned to hear
the case that she has raised of her
constituent decisions it's absolutely
right the decisions on delivery of
services should be taken by local
conditions they are because they are
best place to assess local need now I
understand that what the local NHS is
doing is looking at the very
considerable challenges that are being
faced by epicenters and Talia trusts and
looking at options for future services
but these are at a very early stage and
I'm knowing knowing the Honourable lady
as I do from past experience when we
shared supposed sat on Merton Council
together I'm sure that she will continue
to raise the concerns of her local
constituents and I would encourage her
to do so Julian Knight
surely 34,000 copies of your money
matters a free personal finance textbook
will wing their way to every secondary
school in the land well I'll write or
friend join me in saying thank you to
its funder the broadcaster Martin Lewis
Young Money the organization behind it
the a PPG for financial education and
young people which I chair are not least
the department education for making this
fantastic resource for our young people
happen can I can I say to my own
boyfriend I think he's done a very
important thing today by raising
people's awareness of this booklet which
I think would be extremely important for
secondary schools I think this is a
really good piece of work I congratulate
all those who are involved and I know
this is an issue that my honourable
friend through his chairmanship of the a
PPG has taken very seriously has been
championing for a long time and I hope
he's pleased to see this piece of work
being done I'm sure he want to carry on
to ensure there is that financial
education taking place so that young
people are prepared for their future
lives merry cry to speak of the economy
is stalling business investment is
falling
[Applause]
I couldn't care less what somebody
transferring from a sedentary position
says ezel isn't the truth what I care
about is that the Honourable lady will
not be shouted down any more than any
other member in this place will be
shouted down be quiet and listen Mary
Kray stalling
business investment is plummeting and we
have the grotesque spectacle of Tory MPs
putting party interest before the public
in July if she survives tonight's vote
will she finally rule out No Deal
facedown her hard Craig cities let this
place vote down her deal and put it back
to the public in a people's vote the
Honourable lady first of all the way to
if she wants to ensure No Deal the way
to ensure No Deal is to agree a deal
that is the best way to ensure but there
is not New Deal
that's the way to ensure this it is not
no deal but she talks about the economy
she talks about the economy employment
is at a record high wages wages are
growing and we've had 23 consecutive
quarters of growth the longest run in
the g7 that's a balanced approach to the
economy that's conservatives delivering
for the people of this country some
Patrick McLoughlin can I ask my right
honorable friend to take her mind back
to September 97 when a referendum was
held in Wales the result of that
referendum was 50.3% in favour of an
assembly and 49.7% accounts on a turnout
of 50 percent nobody questioned whether
we should accept the referendum does
that hold any future reference for us
can I thank my right honorable friend
he's made a very important point and
he's made a very important point about
the principle that was accepted at that
time which was however small the margin
in the vote it was the overall result of
the vote that should be accepted and
acted on Jill furnish Thank You mr.
speaker last week I hosted an event to
raise money for Radio Hallam FM's
mission Christmas a charity doing
fantastic work helping children in need
in my constituency and for the local
food banks indeed many of the 41% of
children living in poverty in my
community will really need help this
Christmas what message does the prime
minister have for those who are working
hard set will make ends meet but will
find themselves forced to rely on food
banks for their family's Christmas meal
and mission Christmas for their
children's presents
[Music]
can I can I first of all and obviously
say how good it is that Radio Hallam has
been doing this work there are many
charities up and down the country who do
do work to ensure that they can provide
a better Christmas for many children
than they would otherwise have that is
important we don't want to see we don't
want to see people be relying on food
banks but the way to in the way to
ensure that people are able to provide
for themselves without having to rely on
food banks is to ensure that people are
in work that that work is well paid and
that work always pays which is exactly
what we're doing
Maggi through
residences are awash are clear that we
need a strong government to deliver on
brexit and on the domestic agenda does
my writeable friends agreed that it's
time for us to unite on these benches as
the real threat to our great nation is
the party opposite in the labour
government can I echo the comments that
my honourable friend has made I think
many people many members of the public
want us to get on with brexit and
actually ensure that we are delivering
for them on the domestic agenda like the
record number of home new homes that
we've seen being built the best number
ever bar one year in the last 31 years
it's getting onto that domestic agenda
that is important to do that we must
unite as a party and bring our country
back together again she's absolutely
right the greatest threat to the jobs
and livelihoods and futures of her
constituents and constituents around the
United Kingdom would be a Labour
government in Fletcher last month in my
constituency a 16 year old boy was
tragically killed in a knife attack this
came as knife crime has almost doubled
in Coventry over the last five years I
know that some good multi-agency work is
happening in this field but does the
Prime Minister still think we have
enough police officers on our streets to
be able to fight crime and the fear of
crime
can I first of all extend my condolences
to the family of the constituent that
the Honourable lady has referred to and
who has suffered from this terrible
attack can I also say the hoof obviously
there is a concern I recognize the
concern about the rise in violent crime
it's why the government has produced
this serious violence strategy the
serious violence task force state has
people from across the house in sitting
on that across party bases sitting on
that it's why we've given extra powers
to the police to tackle knife crimes
through we're giving that through the
offensive weapons bill and we've
strengthened firearms control through
the policing and crime act and in
relation to this isn't just about police
action actually we've announced the 200
million youth endowment fund which will
be about helping to work with young
people who otherwise might find
themselves drawn into gangs and the use
of knives to prevent them from doing
that and to print these crimes from
taking place in the first place
[Music]
just by right honourable friend share my
concern and my constituents concerns
about the further delays and increased
costs of Crossrail and the failures of
TfL and the labor mayor of London I
absolutely share my honorable friends
concerns at his constituents concerns
and indeed my constituency is affected
also by the delay of cross rail and yes
we should recognize the role that TfL
and the Labour Mayor of London has plays
in this we want to see cross rail it's
going to be a benefit to my own will
friends constituents and mine and the
Labour mayor needs to get his finger out
on this
in 1997 the British Prime Minister
issued an apology to the people of
Ireland for the historic roles in the
Great Famine a famine that saw a million
people died and a million people
displaced from their homeland that sent
our powerful and an important message
well the Prime Minister condemned any
notion any suggestions the food churches
in Ireland will be used to strengthen
Britain's negotiator panel
can I say can I say to the honorable
gentleman I am happy to absolutely give
that assurance we would not use that
issue in any sense in the negotiating
strategy we want to work with the Irish
government to ensure that we are
providing a good brexit for the UK a
good brexit for Ireland and I believe
that would be a good brexit for the
European Union Neil O'Brien you mr.
speaker one of my constituents you know
would be written to me to say I voted
for exit and I urge you to support our
Prime Minister unreservedly and
virtually sprigs of the Prime Minister
has done a terrific job in trying
circumstances the headbangers from all
sides and the supine aptitude of the
Labour Party as men she's had an
impossible job but she's done so well
finally a third from standing turn
rights I'm an employer of 30 people in
the harbor a constituency to vote
against the deal will cause political
chaos and opened the door to worse
possible scenario for this country
far left labor government does the Prime
Minister agree with me that my
constituents have got a lot more common
sense than the members opposite who want
to stop Briggs it and fundamentally
damaged our democracy
I think mr. speaker I think mr. speaker
this can be an occasion where I give a
very short answer yes
Rachel master on this Parliament this
week it's emblematic of the way this
government have consistently treated the
people of our country in the light of
the Prime Minister's conduct the pound
has fallen 2 percent over the last 48
hours running the entire NHS for six
weeks the Prime Minister believe that
this is a Christ's words pavement is
doing for the NHS it is this government
that is establishing a 10-year plan for
the sustainability of the National
Health Service and it is this government
that is putting the biggest cash boots
in its history into the National Health
Service to ensure it is there for all
our constituents now and in the future
does the Prime Minister agree that we
all owe a huge debt of gratitude to our
police officers prison officers and
probation staff who are in the frontline
of keeping us all safe the first duty of
any government in that regard could I
please ask the Prime Minister to take a
close and personal interest in the
2019-20 police funding settlement can I
agree with my honourable friend I think
we do owe an enormous debt of gratitude
to all those who were on the front line
putting themselves potentially at risk
for us that is police officers but he's
also referenced prison officers and I
think probation officers he referenced
as well and I can assure him that I have
been looking at with the Home Secretary
as he has at the 2019-20
a police funding settlement Caroline
Lucas
the plotters behind her know that any
replacement Prime Minister would face
exactly the same party arithmetic and
exactly the same deadlock on brexit this
deadlock can only be changed by going
back to the people The Times newspaper
today also said it's her only chance of
saving her job and saving her deal so
can she tell the house what exactly is
she afraid of honorable lady the issue
is the issue is that this house
overwhelmingly voted to give the choice
to the British people as to whether or
not to leave the European Union the
British people chose to leave the
European Union and I strongly believe
that it is the duty of members of this
house to deliver on that vote mr.
speaker what does the Prime Minister
consider to be most important playing
parliamentary parlor games in this place
or protecting jobs and businesses by
going back to the negotiating table and
thrashing out a deal that will pass
through this house
when I say to our girlfriend I think it
is in the interests in the interests of
employers and the interests of people
whose jobs are at stake in this to make
sure that we get a good deal with the
European Union and that's why it's
important that I was in Europe yesterday
and will continue to be in Europe doing
exactly as he says negotiating the deal
that I believe can get the support off
this house to ensure that we can move
forward and deliver a good brexit
finally some incent Gabel yes does the
Prime Minister judge that it is more
welcome or more appropriate to face a
no-confidence motion from her
backbenchers or from the leader of the
Opposition
[Applause]
to the right honourable gentleman but
that is not obviously we have one of
those which is going to to take place
what I want I think is important for
everybody in this house is to recognize
that we have a I believe a solemn duty
to deliver on the result of the
referendum in 2016 I believe the best
way of doing that is with a good deal
with a good breaks it deal with the
European Union that protects jobs and
honestly referendum and I believe that's
the deal we've negotiated order
these questions wrapping up their
unendurable Prime Minister's Questions
I'd say that ordinarily the audience is
obviously the people in the chamber but
also those in the wider world watching
on television today